i don't know the statistics but like a
lot of women earn probably a lot more
yes from only fans than men do and this
is the first platform where men are like
wait because everything else like you've
seen the pay gap everything like that
this is the one thing where they kind of
excel at the kind of thing
do you think
no it's not real is it no no no like
through my industry 100 no there's i've
seen a lot of even actresses and actors
say like they've done the same show same
modeling modeling women make more in the
modeling industry if you take into
account so the thing is they're not
taking into account personality traits
so 60 of women have never in their life
asked for a raise and they'll quit their
job before they ask for it right if
we're not choosing to ask for a raise we
can't be mad if we're paid less yeah and
we're picking industries that we don't
get paid as much what about those sorry
what about those that do ask for a
reason that denied yeah
if they if they ask for a raise and
they're denied they probably don't have
the skills